i guess we've gotten a lot of the basic
things out of the way of like your first
visit to japan what if what if someone
has a little bit more time and has been
to japan a few times where would you
guys recommend that that they go to well
i mean i you know we did this the shima
nami kaido which is on the cycling
special honestly
like that inland sea area is [ __ ]
beautiful gorgeous [ __ ] incredible
and i've really really since the cycling
special i really want to go back there
like i really want to go back there and
do the route again basically just just
look at the spike this just look at the
cycling special and just look how
[ __ ] beautiful it was because the
best thing about it is that like you
have you know all of like hiroshima
that's near there you have right next to
that there's a prefecture called okayama
yeah uh where i went there for a video
um
there's this like little small town
called kurashki which is like this
really [ __ ] cool retro style town
yeah that's just basically just like
this hill that overlooks the inland sea
and it's so [ __ ] gorgeous and then if
you want to cross that inland sea and go
to like shikoku uh you you have places
like ehime which is really like kind of
down to earth and like kind of chill
yeah
okay
not the most it's not the most exciting
thing but like if you're a little bored
of like yeah if you're a little bored of
like the kind of whole city life of
tokyo and stuff like that in the main
cities uh that's really really nice yeah
and if uh if watching the cycling
special kind of like intimidated you uh
don't worry you don't need to do the
entire route in a day um if i was to do
it again i would definitely not do it in
a day you can also rent a car just drive
across you can also rent a car but if
you also want to keep healthy you know
keep keep
you know work out those muscles then i
do actually highly i highly recommend
the cycling route um i highly recommend
you do that in uh two days maybe three
days you know what if
now that you think back what was what do
you think is like the optimal time you
would recommend i would call that a day
you were still doing a day yeah i reckon
if i didn't want to be hurting i'd say
at least two days i think it was just
annoying because we were filming i think
it would have been not pretty fun if i
could just power there's a couple of
like the islands in between where
admittedly there isn't a whole lot going
on but like the first couple of islands
uh you know that's like closer to like
hiroshima there's like still a really
like cool like town vibe to it and you
know there's like a lot of like cool
beaches there as well so if you go yeah
yeah yeah it's like there's some
genuinely nice beaches there for the fit
you are i guess if you really aren't fit
at all i wouldn't yeah maybe just stick
to the first island yeah yeah yeah but
you know if you're somewhat active and
you you know you'll have no problem
cycling then yeah i just do it all in
one day it's very you can also just
cycle around hiroshima as well yeah yeah
i mean honestly it's like some of the
most beautiful views i've had in japan
yeah not saying a lot because a lot of
japan is photogenic as [ __ ]
so it's a bit unfair i mean i i guess
sticking on that vein um
if you want to go see mount fuji um i do
recommend going to one of the lakes
around there i can't remember the name
exactly
but like
how good should you go
like we like lake ouguchiko is just like
you can also cycle around there you can
rent a bike me and city have
gone on a date where we've rented a bike
and just cycled around the entire lake
it's kind of unfair
where you go to a place and everything
looks photoshopped even though it's real
like you you take a picture there uh
we've taken a bunch of pictures there i
don't know uh we've uh when the last
time we went there was the uh we went
camping right when we went camping yeah
and luke took a bunch of pictures and we
took a bunch of pictures and everyone
took a bunch of pictures and nowhere
i know and no matter what it was
impossible to take a bad picture it just
looked like a postcard especially when
it's clear yeah yeah yeah
yeah but um yeah
yeah i don't know because like i
remember when we did the journey across
japan 2 to mount fuji yeah a lot of
people thought that
by the end of it we had just like green
screened ourselves in front of it
because it just looked that good it's
it's it's so weird being in that place
and you just like i literally look like
i let you feel like i'm looking at the
green screen or like it's this is a this
is a screensaver right like a desktop
yeah i'm looking at a screen saying i'm
waiting for
yeah
it's it's so surreal that a place can
look that photogenic but just exist in
real life without any uh without any
plug-ins or any uh any photoshop edits
no rtx no yeah yeah yeah no rtx on well
it's probably one of the places you
might want to drive though it's kind of
annoying to go by train and stuff yeah
there isn't a whole lot of traffic i'd
say like outside of the major cities
like osaka um tokyo sapporo and stuff
like that um
driving is your best friend you
literally like
you'll have such a hard time if you're
trying to do it by public transport as
i'm sure
probably is uh experience because you
only do it all by public transport yeah
yeah actually uh on that vein i guess an
app i highly recommend uh is the app
that we use is a dd
which um there are there is like a few
taxi apps in japan uh
taxi but uh dd is the most i guess
foreigner friendly because it's you can
uh full english so it's all english so
except for any card yeah it will accept
any card with with other apps it's been
really finicky with the types of cards
that it will accept japan taxi and go
taxi whatever it is now oh yeah god it
is i have a japanese card and she keeps
denying it yeah really i have a japanese
card it denies it i haven't so i have a
foreign card it denies it i have like
cards from like
like thailand and the uk and it's just
like it doesn't want to accept anything
it doesn't want to accept anything so i
don't know what card it will accept um
so yeah i like highly recommend dd over
uber here would you say so because i
know you can use uber if you want yeah
you can use uber
yeah i think i think dd is i think
there's more taxis on dd um
yeah and it's and it's the best in
between because dd is not as popular as
a japanese app app like go taxi but it
is still way more
friendly if you unfortunately uber is
just not really a thing here no um
ubereats is but like the actual uber i
know i know some people who use it
religiously yeah um but mainly for food
i guess yeah yeah also hailing cabs is
really really easy here
especially together if you you know if
you're confident enough and just telling
them where to go uh it's really really
easy yeah obviously that's a big if yeah
i understand it's at all but i think for
the most part if you're in tokyo the
train system is just so convenient you
probably google very rarely will have to
don't try to learn the maps just use
google maps yeah that's pretty simple it
routes it out for you following anyone
who follows this
is absolutely lying google literally
knows the best route i'm i'm i wish that
people would shut up being like i know
the streets better no you don't google
google has every [ __ ] satellite in
existence
and billions of data it knows whether to
be fair there has been times where i've
looked at google and i'm like nah dude
you're going you're gonna like deal
you're gonna like the aesthetic route
sometimes sometimes google wants to like
make your life easier to a point where
it's like listen it's just quicker if i
just walk yeah yeah yeah they're like no
no we're gonna make it so you don't walk
um
yeah but
google will generally tell you the best
way and you could tell it to fewer
changes or more changes
yeah it's i've it's never failed me in
tokyo yeah even outside of tokyo i'm
driving i use it for driving i use it i
bought one of those shitty little things
on amazon that you stick on like the air
fans oh yeah yeah
hold your phone
yeah it's good i'm good
is there any other places you guys would
recommend a bit out of the box
i've never been to kyushu do you think
joey is good kyushu is great uh i i
think kyushu is underrated as hell yeah
um i one place i really really liked in
kyushu was um kumamoto yeah um
yeah the yeah where aso is the volcano
mount also is yeah but like i think
kumamoto is really cool because it's
like it's again this like huge like
volcanic caldera but it's also like it
weirdly reminds me a lot of like the
kind of like plain uh open plain places
that i went to a lot in like australia
and like in england and stuff like that
yeah it doesn't look like japan right
and it's so weird but like it's really
really cool if you like your like kind
of mountainous areas it's really dope
and also you're really close to like
nagasaki as well which is a really dope
city
um nagasaki is a super cool city that's
like very like vintage feel it has like
a very european feel as well because
like a lot of the a lot of like european
settlers came in and out of nagasaki um
yeah i don't know kyushu i think is
really underrated has some really good
food as well i've always wanted the game
yeah that's really cool yeah i still
haven't been to kyushu as well you can
go to oita as well which has the other
really massive onsen area
yeah
everywhere is a really cool onsen place
as well gotta fly there i wouldn't
recommend taking the bullet train you
can take the bullet train
but it's like yeah seven or eight hours
so i didn't know it was that far
i mean to hiroshima it's like five hours
all right
and that's not even
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean like i
guess one place that i don't really hear
people talking about is obviously like
if you're a wine lover like me and
sydney are uh you can go to the wine
capital of japan even though like wines
not as well known here but i mean we
discovered the place because we're not
like i'm not a big sake fan you know i'm
not a massive sake fan but there are
plenty of places to try sake in tokyo
and basically anywhere you go into japan
but if you want to have a little taste
of the japanese wine culture here
because it's not very well talked about
you go to koshu valley it's in the
yamanashi prefecture which is like you
can literally make it a day trip oh you
wanted to um it's like just about like
an hour an hour and a half out of tokyo
uh you can literally just go on on the
jr line and go to
go to the stops around kosher valley um
there is one place i do recommend if you
are interested uh i believe the building
is called budo no
i think
yeah
um i believe that's the place uh because
that's the place i've talked about
before where you can go in and they have
a wine cellar
with about a hundred different wines you
pay 13 bucks and you can try as many
wines as you like and uh
it's self poor they give you they give
you a they give you a little cup and uh
you can try as many ones you like
there's there's little bowls where you
can spit out the wine if you don't like
the taste of the wine you know um
it's just 13 bucks to get mounted on
wine yeah i've done it i've done it
plenty of [ __ ] times it's a really
really good experience and then there's
a really nice restaurant up there
go in there for a yearly trip uh to try
out the different wines there that's
come out every year yeah you can i i
think i drove there in this decent
parking but if you do like sake i would
recommend niigata you got to ah yes
is like the the capital of sake and like
rice fields and stuff yeah i went to a
similar
thing like to the wine
except it was all sake
for like 20 bucks and you could like
taste test yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's two stations to have it yeah
it's basically like all throughout
niigata it's just like all really really
nice like sake-based stuff
yeah so if you like sake go to niigata
if you like wine go to yamaha but also
in the negative vending machines the
there's also uh umeshu plum wine oh yeah
it's like nectar of the gods
it's wonderful it's just like
sugary goodness oh it's so good it's
very it's so bad for you though yeah
like 100 sugar unfortunately sugar
actually umeshu is a bit too sweet for
my palette otherwise i probably would
like i couldn't drink it straight but
like you know you're mixing it up like
soda yeah yeah i mean
it's pretty i've been there a bunch it's
okay there's not really much to do there
but the vending machine is sick yeah
there are ski resorts near it so in the
winter if you're coming
which is a really very popular decent
ski resort and i mean tohoku area in
general no one really goes to but it's
pretty chill i've been there a town
obviously with chris sure you have as
well yeah i love to army and talkers my
family's frontal yeah right i mean
sendai's chill yeah
it's fun
in japan
of course
i mean
morioka is really fun
a lot of cool areas of the north that
doesn't really ever get spoken about as
a tourist destination yeah i think it's
because talk is just so big
a lot of the biggest like i mean i think
iwater is the second biggest prefecture
after
hokkaido it's a cool place though i've
had some really amazing food and drink
in that area and it's just kind of nice
to go somewhere because especially if
like kyoto is too touristy for you yeah
definitely tohoku oh yeah not gonna have
tourists definitely yeah uh and it's
it's a good time way way fun with
crystal
yeah because i mean like especially like
one of the biggest things about kyoto is
that it's just like too crowded and you
can get it's like proud of even now and
i don't know is it crowded now that's
sort of crowded i mean uh i don't know
some some seasons i've been it's been
dead depends on the day you go obviously
weekdays is dead yeah um but some
weekends are still busy so i'm like god
forbid you come here on a on a like
peak tourist is there like a prefecture
or like area of japan you've always
wanted to go to but you haven't been yet
kyushu i was like
i really still haven't been to and
really want to go to aomori
because it's like it's in between
hokkaido and the yeah like
i'm just like why would i not just go to
hokkaido at that point yeah almond has
like really cool like you can do like
apples
yeah
really good food like really nice like
winter wonderland places yeah i've heard
it's really fun
what about um theme parks because uh
huh you've never been i'm not huge i
mean you've still been to disneyland
though haven't you yeah i don't like
disney though i'm awful i'm the wrong
person yeah i don't like theme parks
either but usj is pretty fun in all
soccer i've been to usj yeah yeah it's
decent you just said you've not been to
any theme parks and you've literally
lied
you've literally been to like two of the
biggest all the big the biggest one fuji
q i haven't been to so i feel like my
opinion doesn't count but like yeah i
mean fujiku is more like the six flags
right it's it's the thrill scene yeah i
i like thrill rides and i was kind of
disappointed by usg i thought there's
gonna be more thrill rides i don't know
why i think you're better off in fuji
yeah i figured i'll probably like fujiki
more
because i hate thrill rides and i went
to fujiku and i'm like oh if you love
thrall rides this is yeah
you can go to a roller coaster and have
a view of fuji how awesome is that right
like that's that's pretty badass yeah
where's where does where's thought park
with that
what does thor park out what the [ __ ] is
thought park have the car park ah
well thought park's good what the [ __ ]
you want about
it is good it is good it just said just
like how can it like you know
i i think fuji i mean fuji is just like
one of the best have you been to
you've been to fuji queue i've i've been
outside it and i've like oh great i've
driven past it
no [ __ ] on thought park hold on
i'm not i'm not sitting on thought park
but um i mean we all drove past fuji q
when we went [ __ ] camping i am did we
yeah i was [ __ ] asleep
i didn't remember that but like it was
just it was just a really nice aesthetic
area i don't know i just like
it's good but you know i mean come on
snow snow it can't be no thought no no
nemesis inferno town so is it it's about
one time we gotta take you i think all
these theme parks though yeah
he literally just said he's really like
i don't like thorough rides or theme
parks i thought you're just joking no i
don't [ __ ] usj usg nintendo land
is the only one i liked but that's
obvious because i'm a nintendo sam why
don't you what why i don't know i'd
rather go [ __ ] to the arcade or watch
a movie